justement on va parler du casting de
dallas dans un instant arrive je pense
que delphine j'aimerais beaucoup voici
une danse avec nicolas pernikoff le
roomba nom et dans quelle rumba
l'attendu
stratosphérique plus tôt c'est quoi 13
en l'air comme ça
vous avez pu le voir le dauphin il va
pas bien le savez
pas comment vous sentez au niveau du
mental je suis jamais senti aussi solide
c'est ce qu'a dit mon meilleur ami qui
est en dépression depuis six mois se
voit quand par exemple merde quoi quand
tu te sens solide c'est souvent quand tu
es dans le creux des emmerdes je me suis
jamais senti aussi mais je me suis
jamais donné la qualité il a été
convoqué au commissariat
dépression
au commissariat on voit combien avaient
peur parce qu'ils ont dit tu lire demain
et je peux vous dire il a chié dans son
camp
alors des gens à part un petit dans des
cimetières yacine perrier cdma le tango
citoyens comme vous seraient bourg le
même sa banque surtout leur choix
là bas il faut la musique près
[Applaudissements]
hier
danse avec leurs maps
non mais ça merci merci patron voulait
trouver il était dégueulasse merci
n'aurait divers daysi danse comme vers
la corne à la police on dirait vraiment
l'oncle quand tu sais qui vaille maritza
il devait l'investir décoller et
delphine n'est pas mal ouais mais quand
les gens regardent trop dans les yeux
quand il danse avec mu c'est un peu
gênant s'est retiré à se ressentir la
danse on va essayer de 2,2 était trop la
personne embellie venons mais je
t'explique lui l'année
prochaine
il faut dire qu'elle a fait des semaines
qui fait qui pour lui ne les connais ils
à faire à manon il a fait qui pourrit le
drame amoureux